We have succeeded in creating a corporate culture centered around innovation
Develop new features and address emerging challenges
We are the company responsible for operating the LIFULL HOME'S real estate website
Anyone planning to move to a new home
It is looking centrally and for a short time
Most of our queries come from computer pages
Or mobile browsers
And a little smartphone application
But I think applications allow for deeper and greater connectivity
Our mission is to increase the number of inquiries we receive through our application
That's why we focused on "users first" and "user happiness"
Our goal is to develop an application that meets user expectations
Listening to our users is vital to achieving this
So we started to answer every comment we get
Three members of the Panel have rotated on this process
Through personal communication, users can see people behind the scenes
We conduct surveys and use results to help improve the app
Then we test A / B on 50% of the ingredients
If it succeeds, try 100%
The decision to introduce Bottom Navigation was the cause of several disagreements in the company
But we decided to give it, for our convenience
So we used the Firebase Remote configuration to perform the A / B test
The reactions of the users were positive, confirming our chances of survival and adoption
One of the key performance indicators we closely examined was the conversion rate in the app
Using Bottom Navigation has increased the conversion rate by 1.5 times
It also allowed us to improve the screen utilization rate
LIFULL users have a clear AIM target
The design is intuitive, the structure is good
And even geometry, have all been identified in the multidimensional design
Everyone in our team agrees that this move was successful
We work with the spirit of "user first"
We used the A / B test from Developers Console
To perform A / B tests on Store Screens and Application Operator Token
This has resulted in a 188% increase in stabilization rates.
These figures confirm the effectiveness of our user-centric approach
User queries across the application are the main internal performance indicator
It increased by 166% from last year
Our Play Store rating increased from 3.5 to 4.2.
We're very grateful for the feedback we've received from users
We look forward to continuing our work on Google's new core systems
Providing innovative services to the industry.